I'm thinking of the song right now and I
have read you felt this was the first
time you really wrote a very serious Van
Halen lyric well I wrote the lyrics when
we started that record and I kept
singing them to Eddie right now and he
you know yeah okay I said just try to
write something I really got this great
thing I thought it was really good I was
laying on the beach it was time to go to
the studio and I and you know my wife
shelling up at at top hey you got to get
going I'm said man I'm going man I just
want to be here right here right now and
I oh there you go so I started writing
that lyric and Ed had this piano part at
the same time and he kept saying you
know like the Joe Cocker song like
feeling all right I'm going man I ain't
hearing it I ain't hearing it I ain't
hearing it he ain't hearing my lyric all
of a sudden at the end of the album 6
eight months later we took a long time
making that record all of a sudden I
heard it he was playing a piano just
goofing off and I go right
now boom done that was a free freakiest
song we ever wrote together cuz it was
great but it was just weird that we
neither one of us we didn't communicate
well on that song and I think it's one
of your most successful songs it it
really was got more you know Awards and
stuff than anything we had done and
honestly in concert we play this song
all the time in the circle and it's like
yeah that's when the audience just they
just scream right now it's it's one of
those I Can't Drive 55 moment you
know you know and would you do a little
of it let's celebrate theour that It Go
[Music]
Dog and the one on this song is so
freaky nothing is on the downbeat it's
all it's like
[Music]
popcorn
great piece of music wow
[Music]
wow
don't want to wait till
tomorrow why put it off another
day one by one little
problems build up and stand in our
way one step ahead one step behind
it and now we got to run
[Music]
to make future plans to dream about
yesterday come on turn turn this thing
around now
it's y
tomorrow now come on it's
everything right now it's your Magic
Moment do it right here
now it means everything you miss the
beat you lose the
Rhythm nothing falls in the
place
only miss my
fraction slip the little off your
p and the more things you get the more
you
want we trading one for the
other working so hard trying to make it
easy time to turn turn turn this thing
around
[Applause]
now hey it's on
tomorrow now come on it's
everything right now it's your Magic
Moment do it right here
now tonight means
everything it's a
lightning
do it right
now what are you waiting
[Music]
for turn this thing
around right
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
Joe SRI come on man no
rehearsal now come on is
everything now it's a Magic Moment good
right here now
woo right
now is what's happening
[Music]
here right here
now right
now com me what you wait
[Music]
tomorrow it's too far
away tomorrow it's too far
[Music]
away do it do it do it do it do it do
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it
W first time we ever played that wow wow
you guys man that wasn't the L Howard
that that was beautiful you need you
need Joe santani if you're going to play
that